yeah any way to welcome to this video
saying book slick you have played in the
form yet it's a line that Jeff that we
had the wireless channel and it's not
good for black let's see light 0 and we
should be three are both good I think
this is probably even more precise not
sure you please knight c6 I mean now
you're just using material and I'm an
exchanger by it exactly the same game
very recently so let's take this yeah I
wonder a four or I can also just cover
it what is an extreme job and that's it
basically for absolutely nothing
yeah I thought that there should be some
winning texted now this looks oh
absolutely unplayable so bouquet seven
or so near quincy six they don't are now
97 of course uma that soviet game
yeah I there was what k that there was
some kind of desperation thing coming
but I can just take Here I am check and
I'm a rope up jack
yeah how do i get the night out of them
probably cheese the bishop down
and he's continuing this here somehow
can I can I chick made or something to
NDA probably not
check black resigned bit pointless ready
sorry of it I can design whenever you
want but it's just a waste of time I
mean it's lost after move 8 so check
anyway so edit deadline as mentioned
multiple times it's not playable for
black after 93 I mean maybe you can
somehow hold whatever but it's really
really really really not good 11 point
is that jess is not okay and then 93 we
should be too late winning the Queen
yeah and here after that you see the
engine i can switch it on plus two it's
it's it's already gone there and I
thought 96 is a bit tougher but yeah
this is this is also pretty much toast
and why shouldn't it yeah you move the
Queen a ton of times and you weaken the
position so a success were really weird
90 of sixes the only move that continues
and I had this in a in a tournament game
last year and I could not quite remember
the theory like the five is strongest in
i played this which is also better for
white but not as good as it can be m i
also got a winning position out of the
opening in that game but nite nite the
five is even a bit stronger it's black
now takes there should be three Quincy
six in a 54 yeah like just it's just it
just not playable yeah ok guys thanks
for watching